ich habe vor zwei monaten schon mal so
ein ähnliches video hochgeladen 1,6
millionen aufrufe dann habe ich mich vor
einem monat noch mal der ganzen sache
gestellt eine million aufrufe
das hat mir einfach gezeigt dass wir es
feiert denn ich leide wenn ich sehe wie
andere leute leiden deswegen schauen wir
uns heute wieder eines der teams
compilation an
ich habe mir wieder ein video
rausgesucht das einfach mal satte 22
millionen aufrufe hat ich mein werk ist
nicht wahrscheinlich habe er gar nicht
mal so viel
hier klicken jetzt einfach mal auf play
und sehen schon der ton ist an bester
war ja klettert die leiter hoch klatscht
sich ab mit seinem ich kann mir so was
nicht geben ich finde das ist eine geile
aufnahme von der kompletten stadt so du
siehst du alle hochhäuser aber höher mit
dem fuß er überlegt man derweil aus ok
ich finde das geht noch also ich meine
es ist ja ein bisschen höher
das ist ja eigentlich bin style ich
werde das ist halt dieser freerunner wir
klettern überall hoch damit die ok das
ist auch schon sehr sehr eng hier gerade
aber das geht auch volvo
warum ist mitten im niemandsland 40.000
meter turm leute schaut euch das einfach
an hier ist im ganzen umkreis nichts das
ist keine riesige großstadt und hier
sagt david turm der ist doch easy 300
meter hoch wir haben dann safestick am
start film sich dabei wie die da oben
drauf stehen hier ist mein gott der
typen dieser der
weiter ohne spaß leute gebt euch diesen
typen warten einig zeigen euch zeigen
euch zeigen euch zeigen euch dieser typ
der ist in jedem zweiten scared of heitz
video mit drinnen dir ist wieder der
gleiche typ einfach barfuß ich glaube
nämlich solche ähnlichen szenen hatten
wir schon beim letzten video mit dabei
aber ich meine leute ja genau das war
die szene wo wir glaube ich das jetzt
mal aufgehört haben er hängt an einer
fucking brücke über eine autobahn nimmt
sogar seine hand fällt jetzt sieht er
sich wieder hoch der hier klettert jetzt
glaube ich auch gegen eine brücke hoch
somit ist schaut er darunter als ich
dachte schon er hängt sich dran oder
irgendwie so war es okay dass es habe ja
das ist wieder der spaß der typ ist in
jedem video mit dabei ich weiß nicht was
sein lebensziel ist oder was er damit
erreichen will dass er hier so komisch
rüber läuft oder so aber das ist doch
einfach nur krank
okay er läuft sogar irgendwann gerade
drüber verstehe ich auch nicht wieder da
überhaupt hochgekommen ist
wahrscheinlich hoch geklettert
hier ist wieder der komische typen
irgendwo auf gegen dem stern da oben ist
ein hochhaus da
okay wer kennt es nicht unter hose und
hellem
er läuft damit seinen nackten füßen lang
hier ist wieder einer im schnee ich
finde im schnee ist es auch noch viel
schlimmer ich meine wenn man irgendwie
turner ist oder man macht das relativ
häufig dieses frühe kleinwägen dann ist
es natürlich so dass man dann eine
gewisse balance in seinem körper dass
man weiß okay wie muss ich mich jetzt
bewegen dass ich hier nicht auf die eine
seite runter fall oder so aber hier im
schnee ist es halt so easy einfach
abzurutschen oder so hier ist ein typ
einfach in einem zug ich glaube das
hatten wir sogar wirklich alles letztes
mal schon das würde es halt dass sich
die teile auch die ganze zeit
wiederholen aber wir waren hier ca
stehen geblieben
er hängt jetzt wieder hier runter lässt
wieder mit einer handlos überlegt
überleg mal los
acht jetzt ok handy raus holen
jetzt läuft er hier darüber dass dies
wieder der gleiche typ leute es ist
immer der gleiche da ist er auf diesem
jahr ist wieder wer kennt nicht
da hängt ja auch wieder an ihm so
wandern kann da hängen daneben sei mit
seiner hand das ist wahrscheinlich auch
wieder macht dinge die kunden auch
wieder das ist tatsächlich auch wieder
der typ als er die ganze compilation
dann wird nur von einem typen
er steht einfach so auf der reling ist
er jetzt spielt er auch im schnee sag
mal bist du komplett am schalter das ist
wahrscheinlich auch wieder na ja das ist
auch wieder hängt da wieder runter ich
glaube sein beruf ist es von gebäuden zu
hängen ich lege mich wirklich nicht weit
aus dem fenster
er ja schlecht als ich will mich nicht
mehr aus dem fenster den habe ich glaube
dass er das irgendwie beruflich macht er
schneidet dann locker diese videos
zusammengeschaltet der werbung drauf und
verdient damit an cash oder irgendwie so
aber kummer da ist er wieder er hängt
jetzt am kran irgendwo ab und macht dann
noch irgendwelche übungen oder so
trainer seine beine schwingt darum da
ist wieder irgendeiner der irgendeine
autobahnen hochklettert oder so das ist
glaube ich diesmal sogar das ist wieder
der gleiche
das ist tatsächlich wieder der typ leute
zehn euro dass er das ist könnte wetten
10 euro dass er das ist man sieht glaube
ich sein gesicht diesmal nicht sondern
sei sein
nehmt euch kein beispiel an solchen
verrückten lebensmüden menschen spielt
das video mal weiter ab und rede dabei
so ein bisschen hier seht ihr einfach
was passiert da ist wieder dieser
komischer typ mit seiner frau komme
jetzt vertraut er seinem kollegen stefan
vor der typ ist einfach los dann kriegt
der typ nach anzeige wegen fahrlässiger
tötung oder so und er ist einfach tot so
dass sie beide nicht guckt euch das an
walter ich gucke mir das hier an ich
habe gänsehaut ich meine ich habe auch
höhenangst oder so es ist jetzt nicht
also ich habe damit schon so ein
bisschen erfahrung aber ich gucke mir
das an und ich ist für mich sehr sehr
schwierig wirklich das zu kommentieren
bei jedem könnte ich das video
pausierende könnte sagen was er die für
spaß ist aber es ist auch irgendwie
immer der gleiche
wir spielen mal ein bisschen vor bis sie
wieder woanders sind hier haben wir
wieder den typen der von dem hochhaus
runter hängt hier hängt tatsächlich
jetzt mal an der bahnen dahin da wieder
an einem kran hier hängt der wieder ein
hochhaus hier hängt er wieder an einer
stange hier sehen wir ihn wieder an
einem kran mit einer hand das ist der
typ sieht auf simaks okay leute
also das ist max
das ist 100 prozentig mag es ein paar
sekunden später max ich leben gerade ein
video auf hier ist jetzt hier gerade
live im video ich schaue mir das geld
auf heiß vom lächerlich zeigt jetzt mal
wie der typ in dem video außen sieht der
typ aus wie du
der sieht aus wie du wie sie der typ aus
in dem video
der sieht aus wie super
der sieht aus wie war's egal was man
sagt
die max leute schreibt sie die
kommentare schreibt der sieht aus wie
max otte hatte also hier haben wir max
auf gegen dem turm er darüber zeigt dass
hier ist das hätte ich nicht der typ von
vorhin und das hier ist ja auch nicht
der typ weil der ist auch hier viel
durchtrainierter hier tatsächlich also
der typ der hier irgendwelche komischen
posen macht oder sogar hängt wieder max
leute und der typ sieht wirklich
aussieht max eyth hat das könnt ihr mir
ruhig glauben
okay da da ist jeder der typ mit seiner
komischen hose da ist es auch wieder
irgend so ein tier wieder die leute auf
ihrem 400 meter turm mitten im nirgendwo
alter
com
nehmt euch ein beispiel an solchen
menschen das was ihr vom video meine
damen und herren wenn es euch gefallen
hat dass man like dar und bei 60.000
liter ich auf mein bett und laut da
vorne komplett
hier findet jetzt hier vorne ein smiley
eingeblendet wenn ihr darauf klickt
abonniert dem einen kanal das heißt ich
verpasst keine videos mehr ist nice und
man wird ein besserer mensch dadurch da
oben findet ihr auch mein job
eingeblendet am 16 lounge dort eine neue
sommerkollektion hier unten ist ein
anderes video verlinkt also klickt auch
gern mal drauf